the attack was launched in the dead of
night a joint assault by America France
and Britain for RAF Tornado bombers
taking off from Akrotiri in Cyprus on a
mission to punish the Syrian regime for
its use of chemical weapons President
Trump announced the airstrikes in a
mid-evening address to the nation
my fellow Americans a short time ago I
ordered the United States Armed Forces
to launch
precision strikes on targets associated
with the chemical weapons capabilities
of Syrian dictator Bashar al-assad a
combined operation with the Armed Forces
of France and the United Kingdom is now
underway
and there was a strong warning to the
countries propping up the Assad regime
Russia and Iran I also have a message
tonight for the two governments most
responsible for supporting equipping and
financing the criminal Assad regime to
Iran and to Russia I asked what kind of
a nation wants to be associated with the
mass murder of innocent men women and
children the nations of the world can be
judged by the friends they keep no
nation can succeed in the long run by
promoting rogue States brutal tyrants
and murderous dictators the night sky
over Syria was lit up by anti-aircraft
fire but there were no reported allied
losses at the Pentagon the American
defense secretary James mattis said the
targets were exclusively chemical weapon
facilities President Trump
directed the US military to conduct
operations in consonance with our allies
to destroy the Syrian regime's chemical
weapons research development and
production capability the chairman of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff Joseph Dunford
was
most specific about the chosen targets
the first target was a scientific
research center located in the greater
Damascus area this military facility was
a Syrian Centre for the research
development production and testing of
chemical and biological warfare
technology the second target was a
chemical weapons storage facility west
of Homs the British tornados returned
safely to Cyprus the strikes were
carefully coordinated with the US and
France Theresa May had this to say this
evening I have authorized British Armed
Forces to conduct coordinated and
targeted strikes to degrade the Syrian
regime's chemical weapons capability and
deter their use we are acting together
with our American and French allies so
there is no practicable alternative to
the use of force to degrade and deter
the use of chemical weapons by the
Syrian regime French jets were also in
action the French president playing a
leading role in pushing for these
strikes he had said last year that the
use of chemical weapons in Syria would
be his redline the Russians who
apparently did not fire on missiles or
aircraft issued a statement through
their ambassador in the United States a
pre-designed scenario is being
implemented he said again we are being
threatened we warned that such actions
will not be left without consequences
all responsibility for them rests with
Washington London and Paris the White
House says it believes sarin and
chlorine were both used in the attack in
Duma last weekend they hope the
airstrikes means such scenes will never
be witnessed in Syria again
if they are then the Americans say more
attacks will follow whatever happens it
is all but certain that the misery of a
brutal civil war is not over yet
mark Austin sky news in Washington